AMRE MOUSSA >> I am Amre Moussa, the Secretary
General of the Emirate of Arab States. I wish
to respond to the issue pertaining to the
change in the world under the assumption by
Mr. Obama of the office of the President of
the United States. I believe that there will
be a lot of change by Mr. Obama as he promised
in-ah-before his election and as he has shown
that he acted, he moved quickly after-ah-getting
to the white house.
The change has to come first through the system
that was based on the feeding-the hatred between
the western Islam, according to the theories
of the new conservatives that has moved a
lot of the diplomatic moves of the previous
American administration. This has-has to come
to an end to be affected by the change conformed
by President Obama. Not a question of clash
of civilizations. It's not a question of the
priority given to the so-called terrorism
so that everything now is being-you can accuse
any policy of being supporting-supporting-ah-terrorism
just because they oppose the policy of Israel
or the policy of the United States under the
last administration.
So, a lot of change will have to be effective
in the way, in the philosophy, in the concept
behind the policy that's involved.
Number two, they have to make good of the
promises given by the-ah-person of the United
States. We have lost it in 2008. There was
no-ah-fulfillment of the promises given that
2009-the end of 2008 a panacea seemed to be
established alongside the _____. Nothing of
this happened, and not only that nothing-that
we have failed in this-but there was no work.
The work was to procrastinate, to delay and
perhaps to the Arabs that there be-that there
is some work and some meetings and people
are talking to each other, kissing each other,
etc. But there was no substantive work, none.
Therefore we need to have serious work in
order to put an end to the miserable situation
of the Palestinian question and the situation
in Europe.
A Palestinian state will have to be established.
Let us make the year 2009 a year of action
and a year of progress and a year of success
after 2008 has been the year of procrastination,
of delay and of failure.
Now, in addition to the political side, the
economic side. There was a failure in the
economic system, a failure in the international
system that serves the-the economic-ah-international
communications. And in changing that system
and in working together to deal with the may-the
calamity-of the financial crisis I have to
believe we might and I believe that change
has to go in this direction, that is, third
world countries, poor countries, least available
countries will have to be put in the picture.
Their interests will have to be borne in mind.
The system, the world is not only a world
of the rich, but a world of the rich, of the
poor and individuals.